i'm afraid we're now facing an emergency
in our battle with the new variant
omicron
on the day a new record for omicron
cases was broken and the coveted alert
level rose from three to four the words
no one wanted to hear the reaction swift
today we're launching the omicron
emergency booster national mission
unlike anything we've done before in the
vaccination program
to get boosted now
a fortnight ago i said we would offer
every eligible adult
a booster by the end of january
today
in light of this omicron emergency i'm
bringing that target forward by a whole
month
ambitious but the positive message
tinged with a warning act now or more
restrictions may be needed we must
urgently reinforce our wall of vaccine
protection to keep our friends and loved
ones safe
no one should be in any doubt there is a
tidal wave of omicron coming and i'm
afraid it is now clear that two doses of
vaccine are simply not enough to give
the level of protection we all need
but the good news is that our scientists
are confident that with a third dose a
booster dose we can all bring our level
of protection
back up get boosted now to protect our
nhs
our freedoms and our way of life
now the nhs must deliver with the help
of the army and sways of volunteers yet
to be recruited but the pressure on the
system is already great
we're going as fast as we can to extend
the booster campaign but the chief
medical officer had it absolutely right
in the press release a press conference
earlier on um this week when he was
basically saying we need to recognize
how complex
a logistical task it is to run that
booster campaign and we also need to
remember how busy the rest of the nhs is
the language boris johnson used in his
address was stark the promise to the
country ambitious but the problems he
faces in the weeks ahead are huge the
prime minister must make decisions to
protect the nhs from omicron without all
the data decisions that will affect all
of our lives decisions that many on his
back benches will not support and those
political problems are piling up
questions about christmas parties here
in downing street and a worry that the
conservatives could lose a key seat in a
by-election later this week
the address was about convincing the
country to support him yes
but it was about getting his parties
backing too
and the success of that move will be
tested this week as his backbenchers
prepare to line up to vote against his
covert curbs yes i will vote against i
think what we're doing now is creating a
miserable dystopia that into which we're
going forward we've got to show that
there is a movement for that frame of
mind because if we don't the
conservative party will continue to
drift into authoritarianism and i simply
cannot stand idly by while that happens
relying on labour votes to get his
policy through the commons an uneasy
position for boris johnson the prime
minister's lost the authority to lead
he's so weak his party is so divided he
can't provide the leadership we need
at this crucial time he's he's the worst
possible leader at the worst possible
time
boris johnson knows he must prove his
critics wrong this week is the turning
point
a reinvigorated booster campaign and a
by-election win the price of power kate
mccann sky news